bonjour alors tout d'abord que gagne la
france avec cet accord est surtout qu at
elle obtenu par rapport à ce qu'elle
espérait la france a dû accepter c'est
vrai un compromis pour arrêt chez
arracher la signature des pays qui
s'opposaient au plan initial mais
globalement le bilan était positif il
est positif au l'ensemble des
partenaires européens il est positif au
site
pour le l'édifice européen la france et
l'allemagne proposaient un plan de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros dont
500 milliards sous forme de subventions
et aides et 250 milliards sous forme de
prêts remboursables
eh bien on s'est quittés avec un projet
de 390 milliards sous forme de
subventions c'est donc un peu moins de
prévu et 360 milliards sous forme de
prêts remboursables par les pays
bénéficiaires c'est un peu plus que
prévu dont les pays
on appelait les pays frugaux les pays
arabes à dire les pays bas l'autriche le
danemark la suède ont réussi à modifier
l'arbitrage en baissant les haines et
vais donc gratuit et en augmentant les
prêts qui eux sont remboursables mais
mais mais mais la france a quand même
obtenu que tout ça soit financée par de
la dette garantie par l'europe toute
entière et c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois on en parlait depuis des
années que l'europe réussi à émettre de
la dette conjointement à pour tous ces
pays elle sera mutualisé mais au
bénéfice finalement de ceux qui ont eu
le plus de difficultés dans cette
pandémie
alors la france elle va c'est vrai ont
bénéficié de 40 milliards de subventions
ça représente presque la moitié des
cieux du plan de relance français
puisque le plan de relance français des
200 milliards dont 40% ça va représenter
40%
ça reste donc une bonne opération
financière mais l'essentiel n'est pas là
l'essentiel
c'est qu'emmanuel macro et angela merkel
on a bien vu hier soir ont obtenu une
victoire politique parce que cet accord
remet l'europe sur les rails du
fédéralisme c'est assez historique ça
permet à l'europe de repartir le kobe de
19 a obligé les européens à se serrer
les coudes
alors qu'au début de la crise on avait
quand même le sentiment que cette
épidémie a était en train de faire
exploser
non
cette affaire quand même un coup jean
marc hé oui oui elle a un coût oui bien
sûr parce que par ailleurs bas on a peu
raboté le budget de fonctionnement de
l'union européenne 1 venons la rabotées
sur la santé c est vrai que les
politiques de santé sont un peu les
parents pauvres elles sont à la charge
des états mais ça a toujours été sur la
recherche
alors là on a fait un énorme sacrifice
sur la défense nationale
on a fait également à sa crise le budget
de défense de l'europe interdit et ça ça
va gêner la france pourquoi pas parce
que la france est le seul pays en europe
à posséder une arme et d'intervention
avec laquelle d'ailleurs elle intervient
sur un certain nombre de théâtres
d'opération et la force nucléaire et si
les autres pouvaient nous aider un petit
peu en contribuant au financement de
cette époque ça irait quand même un peu
mieux
là c'est un peu une cause perdue et puis
il ya un point sur l'europe a perdu
c'est sur l'écologie l'écologie devait
être à une des priorités des budget
européen à la pandémie mais l'écologie
entre parenthèses on devait notamment
engagé un plan de reconversion des
industries charbonnières aux bénéfices
d'ailleurs de l'allemagne l'allemagne de
l'est
et puis dans l'ancienne allemagne de
l'est puis surtout la pologne la pologne
qui est le premier producteur et le
premier utilisateur de charbon va se
retrouver en toute seule en pester et
elle va empester d'ailleurs toutes les
régions de l'est parce que ce pack
pologne ce retour en comme étant le
premier producteur de gaz carbonique ça
ressemble un peu à du bonneteau vrai
dire on a libéré des subventions pour
lutter contre le coc vite au bénéfice
des pays du sud mais on a vidé son
budget de fonctionnement d'un certain
nombre de postes qui étaient quand même
important et politiquement pensez vous
qu emmanuel macron peut regagner des
points dans les sondages à larissa plan
là grand point d'interrogation grand
point d'interrogation
j'allais dire que politiquement 10 av
l'europe du sud
cette décision va vraiment aider
l'espagne l'italie et la grèce sont là
et maintenant
accro à regagner en légitimité parce que
l'espagne la grèce l'italie et la france
d'ailleurs sont les grands bénéficiaires
du système en france
le ça n'aura sans doute pas beaucoup
d'effet l'opinion publique française
apprécie ou non globalement la politique
économique qui est menée par papa par le
président mais la france n'aime pas le
président bon donc le client public est
très attaché à l'euro mais l'opinion
publique française n'aime pas trop
l'europe
alors le fait que cette europe soit
protégé ne sont finalement une assez
bonne chose parce que des français se
disent bon on va on va avoir des taux
d'intérêt qui vont rester très bas les
taux d'intérêt sont garanties mais
faudra aussi vérifier pas sondages bien
sûr que l'opinion publique créditent le
président de cette politique crédible
président de cette avancée historique
vers le fédéralisme
ça c'est pas sûr que c'est pas évident
du tout merci beaucoup je remarque un
sylvestre d'avoir répondu à nos
questions